Sometimes I see my own reflection, and I think, how am I allowed
To drive a car. This is not a capable thing. This is a fraggle that got stuck in a dryer
(ding dong sound effect)
Hi guys my name is Grace Helbig if you did not know now you know
your life is different now. The Teen Choice Awards happened over the weekend, so let's
judge teen fashion 'cause that's
what an adult woman does. Let's just dive in. Zendaya. Zen-damn-uhhh.
What? She's wearing like a glitter men's pajama set and it's perfect
I'm basically doing the like garbage monster version of this whole look: hair to
straight up pajamas. Tell you what this look won't make you do: fall asleep. It's a good one. I'm just becoming
Actually a stay-at-home dad
What my personality is just slowly morphing into. I don't hate it. I make a lot of spaghetti these days.
2017: worse things are happening. Millie Bobby Brown. You always look so cool all the time
You look like a tiny Bjork. This is not what I would expect
like a 13 year old to ever put on but you look cool
You look like if big bird got a wish from zoltar and his wish was to be like a cool
teenage female actress with a wider emotional range than I'll ever
Accomplish in my life. This is it also available to pitch that movie in a very serious way
I am so able to play big bird if necessary. I play it almost every day of my life. Cute! Rita Ora
Oh girl. This is sexy and fun.
You're just like a sexy Lisa Frank folder. so cute. Bella thorne, why the f***
not, this is like Avril Lavigne. A lot a lot of Avril Lavigne. Avril Lavigne on Avril Lavigne on Avril Lavigne on Avril. This is like
Matrix Avril Lavigne, this is like Ariel the little mermaid is going through an angsty
Rebellious teen phase. Like she'll smoke a cigarette, and then get really light-headed and pretend she loved it.
But really just feel actually nauseous  and never do it again, cute!
Lucy hale is an
Adorable Ai robot she looks so cute and like she's straight out of the forever 21 in Westworld this is fun
I like this outfit
You look very pensive it might have caught you in a moment when your interior programming was rebooting, but still very cute
Vanessa Hudgens, oh girl
I don't even know what era. This is this is like every, Era thrown into one
But I can't stop staring at your barbie crotch. That's so perverted and gross to say
It's just a flat top... don't say these things... feels very glam and luxurious and like you might be throwing a key party later
What stop saying this stuff. Victoria justice!
It was like you were at like a bachelorette party
And they played that game where they had to make your wedding dress out of toilet paper, but you were like uh huh
its 2017 im gonna be wearing a pantsuit to my wedding and so they made you a pantsuit
out of toliet paper but then you were like oh s*** i'm running late for the teen choice awards this works, Let's go!  Maddie ziegler
Why does everyone look so cool and sophisticated and they're young?
What is it?
It's like you took drapes from a very royal Asian household and you made them into this cool two-piece
Yeah, you guys are so much cooler than I'll ever be. Patrick starr. Oh my God. I love
Everything about this. What time is it hammer time because you nail that this is awesome.
Have to stop staring because it's very entrancing. grace vanderwall oh my God
You look so cool a two-piece pink
Businesswoman pantsuit, I've never held a blazer over my shoulder my entire life you just look cool
You look like like beck but as like a young girl. That's a compliment. That's supposed to be a compliment. Beck's very cool
I think he dresses very cool
Oh, Chloe, Kendall Kalani and Nia from dance Mom what I thought this was fith harmony at first
But it's not why do all these young people look so good this is stressing me out
This is very spice girls 2.0. And I'm here for it zigazig ahhhhh
Yeah, good job. There's Fifth Harmony
See you can see how I would think that they look similar except Fifth Harmony looks like they're having a little bit less fun
What they smolder harder, but I like this you all went with solid colors similar shapes
But not identical we got some capes happening
We got some white pants happening it's as if you all kind of decided on the same thing
But none of you wanted to back down. So you're like
We just got a space out how we stand together cute teamwork. GG gorgeous GG
Gg Gg
I'm malfunctioning. Jesus you gorgeous. I don't even know how to describe this but this is adorable. What is this?
This is like you took a napkin from a Fancy restaurant
And you just tied it around the neck you're like I got this and you know what you do got it. Lily Marston
From Clever, you look good girl. What is this a denim and lace
Jumpsuit Romper with light blue hair what how dare you how dare you and also
How dare you? colleen ballinger girl you look
f***ing fantastic everyone looks good
it's getting me excited and angry at the same time
YASSSS
Joslyn Davis another Clever TV Girl looking adorable watch where you're walking girl, cause you got snakes
Skin shoes, sexy. I'm just so happy that internet is there being so beautiful some of us are at home
Experiencing beauty in our own way.  Jake Paul's There being Jake Paul... this looks like Jake Paul
We gotta find you a good tailor because your knees are so strong they're busting out of every pair of pants
I've ever seen you wear. Well there you go that is my review of the teen choice awards
I know I missed a ton of people that you probably wanted me to talk about
But let me know who you thought looked great, and who you thought looked like you know, I don't know
Subscribe to this Youtube channels if you haven't already I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday sometimes